forty-two seconds of logos that are
modified in a cutesy smurfy way at this
point I'm expecting to see some silly
little logo for Korea that tries to
distract me from the 42 seconds of locos
step it up Sony animation is a place
narration goddamnit because of course a
place that knows no sadness immediately
gonna call both on the fact that the
narration says there's no sadness and
Smurf Village there's literally a smurf
named grouchy who's angry and sad all
the time
three apples hi aka three assholes hi
also if Smurfs are supposed to be three
apples tall that's like eight inches or
so which really with every preconceived
notion I ever had about the size of the
Smurfs including the size they're shown
at in this movie The Smurfs are supposed
to be hidden away in a magically
protected village to guard against
people finding them but these Smurf
holes are out riding around in broad
daylight yelling like they're coming
back from a kegger also nobody suggests
Smurfs can control birds these birds fly
through the barrier like it's no big
deal
so how do other non Gargamel predators
not come upon the village even by
accident also I wish you knew how much
this movie's opening two minutes felt
like one of my wife's Disney Tinkerbell
straight to home video movies of course
its Smurfette they're tossing around
haphazardly because the Smurfs are
nothing if not horribly sexist Smurf
Village has a narrator pizza maker and
an ice sculptor and is already the most
pretentious movie society I've ever seen
I just invented frozen pizza no you
didn't end you smoked Domino's Spiros
live in the forest with 99 sons and one
daughter nothing weird about that this
is hit by a character that's made
puppets out of the little creatures with
which he's obsessed
also Gargamel would rather spend the
huge amount of time it takes to create
these smurfy Annette's than just devise
a plan to kill the real Smurfs Gargamel
loves the theater though so
about 2j Oh Hank Azaria that paycheck
dragged you into this didn't I shall
become the most powerful wizard in all
of the world
bleep footage of Gargamel's audition for
now you see me somehow I made it into
the movie look even if this looked real
I'd send the Laughing cat but as it is
I'm going to send the butthole who
decided that CGI laughing cat ended at
the point where the cat looked like a
cross between a puking EMU and a hyena
it's only by capturing the little
wretches and extracting the happy blue
essence that my magic will finally
become invincible yes man that trolls
movie really does Oh Smurf something
wrong hx4 this story magic map that
shows me exactly where the Smurf dude
goes but he's just getting around to
tracking them now how long does he have
that King map the fact that this real
cat is actually supposed to be the same
as that CGI laughing cat further
illustrates the problem with the CGI
laughing cat I see so he's evil but
actually terrible at magic and evil
plans and such for a far superior and
actually entertaining take on this
archetype see dr. Horrible's sing-along
blog Egon get a boy cock and balls you
know we're in a kids movie mmm must get
the visioning portion just right magic
is only strongest during who the fuck is
he talking to oh right us visions this
happen to my Smurfs vision Oracle
prophecy unreliably shows the plot of
the movie cliche clumsy was told by Papa
to stay in the village and immediately
went out to pick the Smurfs root he was
told not to pick clumsy Smurfs name
should be disobedient Smurf no matter
how clumsy is from this point on it's
his disobedience that's the real problem
here the fact that a cat can't catch a
Smurf what did you see in your vision
nothing I know he's trying not to induce
a panic but as soon as Papa saw the
vision of Gargamel shouldn't have told
at least someone he could show up
anytime like now
sound the alarm crazy
why is crazy Smurf the one with the
alarm noise shouldn't you be calling
horny Smurf or something how does crazy
an alarm sounding go together at all
Arthur Mel is literally on top of these
tiny creatures and has a large net but
is able to wrangle exactly zero these
purrs I know he's supposed to be
incompetent but it's almost like he's
trying to screw up Gargamel did so much
mocking that he got a good proper a
walking
har-har the sign is horribly misleading
but what I'm really wondering is why the
other Smurfs ignored look like a normal
sign and what the other way does one of
those things have to do with the other
this goddamn blue moon is the smurfiest
MacGuffin I've ever seen who the wrote
these signs it had to be someone that's
been through the agony of the forbidden
balls and if so how did they make it
back just gonna throw this out there
does anyone care of clumsy dies right
now he's not even well-meaning so far
he's literally tried to put himself in
situations where he'll things up and he
or he didn't notice a goddamn cliff
ahead of him let him go Papa let him go
Jesus Christ it was clearly light when
they ran into this cave and they've been
here for 20 seconds
I bet during screenwriting meetings
anytime someone got stuck someone else
would say just throw that blue moon in
there brilliant for reasons completely
unexplained for the rest of the movie
this exact spot forms a portal to
central fucking Park whenever the blue
moon shows up Papa chooses an unknown
vortex over Gargamel imprisonment that's
a bold choice cotton oh my god they're
in our world I should have known this
was coming but somehow I didn't god
dammit also this movie is a complete
ripoff of enchanted only with none of
the charm plus the most offensive CGI
cat of all time
Smurfs you may want to take a look at
this you may want to Smurf a look at
this cliche my Smurfs are we up the
smurfing creek without a paddle smurfy
Smurfs Smurfs Smurfs Smurfs Smurfs in my
Smurfs Smurfs you lazy ass one joke
movie
but they were our 94 other Smurfs behind
you running through the forest you know
this because you only saw six of them in
here getting sucked through the vortex
so Gargamel's motivation for going
through this vortex is stupid yes he is
stupid but the movie is even stupider is
my point oh hey can we get a
photographer over there there's bigger
rivals happening I'd be tempted to say
something about them dragging Neil
Patrick Harris into this but he was in
those Harold & Kumar movies and a
million ways to die in the whisk then
again he was brilliant in that doctor
horrible show I referenced earlier so
you see the bind I'm in no cliche alert
character who was anxious or depressed
or stressed grabs a drink off a passing
servers tray at a party to represent
their desire to drown their worries in
alcohol cliche seriously think about it
this happens all the time in movies
we're all gonna die I wish you would
look your five-year-old probably loved
this movie but you know what your
five-year-old hilarious gag but both the
cabbie and his passenger would have
heard and investigated that human-sized
thump behind the car fortuitous New York
City worship continues the enchanted
ripoff theme and also rolls Muppets Take
Manhattan into the mix let's see how
many ripoffs we can count in this movie
before it's over jeez between the
references to community Vampire Weekend
and Broadway's American Idiot you might
as well call this 2010 the movie stuff
oh been far away from midtown Manhattan
does Dukie live when they were driving
through Times Square it was the middle
of the day but now it's night again how
much do you need a full time in a Smurfs
movie Smurfs movie there are four King
lamps in this room which is excessive
since I'm fairly sure the room also has
overhead lighting but what I'm really
concerned about is the world's tiniest
dumbbell here on the coffee table
what are these weights for ants the back
of ads we have did fine in focus groups
I could retool those on a clock Patrick
does eventually get those ads ready to
go in addition to a whole other campaign
but works very little over the next two
days well we've had a cat balls joke and
now a puke joke movie is already
competing with Shrek for the most
lowbrow jokes in 100 minutes and now a
porta potty Joe this movie was written
for first graders by fifth graders if
it's that easy to break into Belvedere
castles basement like guarantee there'd
be a sea of homeless people sleeping
there right now and now with the
accidentally waking up the local dog
thing we add Toy Story to the list we're
up to three ripoff skits and less than a
half hour into the film clumsy is that
you what is it about New Yorkers and
movies that always leave their windows
open especially at night
Barney's in the office with the door
closed and Emma from Glee is in bed it's
11:30 7:00 yes he's about to eat soap
because that's hilarious of course it'll
really get Yuka fine laters when he
starts burping bubbles which i guarante
god damn sure as I'm alive tell you he
will do see didn't take eight seconds
writes itself mostly because it's a
series of other movies gags clumsy rube
Goldberg's himself into the toilet which
is a perfect metaphor for this movie
actually this knocks him over look there
are two more lamps in this room we've
yet to be shown that makes six so far so
now we're counting ripoff moments and
lamps in this room I'm not saying I
wouldn't freak out and attack these
things if they suddenly appeared in my
home but I definitely wouldn't assume
they came from the sewers they have hats
only intelligent creatures wear hats duh
sure Gargamel's repurpose that was in
the castle basement but there's no way
he had the tools to tighten those pipe
fittings maybe he called a 24 hour
plumber but if so he got charged out the
ass would you care for a mint when
you're done movie races past wrecked on
the patio meter before the 30 minute
mark does that work you need the essence
of a smurf to catch a smurf and all this
really does is allow Gargamel to blow up
this is exactly what paio said after he
dropped a massive amount of LSD and
started drawing these little person and
you're all named after your
personalities do you get your names when
you're born or after you've exhibited
certain traits Patrick would be
excellent at cinemasins using Google oh
wow they paid for a visual product
placement and a dialogue shout out Jesus
Google basically funded this movie right
also the icon shows that Patrick's
laptop is plugged in which it definitely
is also movie spends all this time
espousing the virtues of Google but
Patrick is using Internet Explorer
instead of Chrome as his browser
Papa stomps all over this laptops
function keys but doesn't cause anything
on the computer to actually happen
clumsy I think it might be best if you
uh you stay here could the movie be
trying any harder to sit clumsy up to be
the hero
goddamnit start in here
alright who smurfed this attempt to blot
the glass walls of his office is
ridiculously inept anyone walking by his
office could easily see the Smurfs I
kissed a smurf and I liked it
oh you moving me without you yeah I mean
who knows why clumsy Smurf is presented
as being completely unaware as to how
clumsy he is which is stupid as hell
also rather than be concerned that these
tiny magical creatures are out and about
in one of the largest cities in the
world grace focuses on Clumsies despair
at being left out homeless dude and a
cat are able to get this close to a
high-level cosmetics demonstration
without encountering any security
whatsoever what you desire reaches fame
fortune um two of those three things
mean the same thing this is a
fascinating win machine which was
nowhere on any of these shelves a few
moments ago also the pin faced hand
spent circuits game is now one shelf
lower than it was earlier and has a
Smurfette imprint on it that Project
Runway guy gets more screen time in this
movie than he does in any episode of
Project Runway also this fine dining
restaurant a lot of cat in then Project
Runway dude ordered cat friendly caviar
then the cat ate the caviar and everyone
acted surprised and put out do I have
that right no Smurfs were killed in the
crossing of this road which is a minor
miracle I'm so checked out I literally
give negative look Chris makes the
schedule and he assigns the writers and
he gave this movie to me and Barrett but
this movie came out in 2011 I'm pretty
sure that means Chris was working at a
theater and it would have seen this
movie because he would have built a
print of it so this is basically a case
where he took advantage of his position
as a schedule maker to ensure that he
didn't have to sit through this a
swiping movie another time and forcing
Barrett and I just suffer and to that I
say bugger - good sir expect the flaming
bag of poop on your porch within the
fortnight crisp I'm serious the Smurfs
hang around in a toy store definitely
qualifies as a gremlins ripoff and I'm
done counting folks too many ripoffs
just add 25 sins for all the ripoffs I'm
just tired of the whole dating game just
say who you are and the lyce weight is
grouchy in the dating game in Smurf
Village because his options are severely
limited bullshit
those tiny toy telescopes never work
especially to do actual stargazing I was
brought by historic like the others I
was created by Gargamel to trap the
other Smurfs because the Smurfs are so
horny and stuff yeah play it safe wait
playing it safe is the carnivorous
picture of the woman as opposed to a
shot of the moon marketing be weird go
it's worse that he plays a video game to
make the Smurfs feel better or that I
literally have no idea if this is rock
band or Guitar Hero Smurfs wrapping this
movie seriously give Smurfette a Marilyn
Monroe vent dress moment because this
movie is oh that's right one of the
central conflicts of this movie is an IT
issue damn I guess even Smurfs movies
feel the need to candle the cat of some
candles you know I miss chef Smurf hefty
Smurf
hey jokey Smurf painter Baker hang on I
thought your Smurf name corresponded to
a personality trait like brainy or
clumsy grouchy but painter and Baker
Smurfs are named after what they do they
were pigeon holed from birth hey guys
drink coffee
this is Smurfs butt blue I don't know
thankfully you all are wearing shorts or
Underpants or whatever so if never been
confronted with wondering what a Smurfs
butt looks like until this movie and
this line from Papa Smurf who was
basically a deviant from what I can tell
never give up on family
Papa Smurf has seen one too many fast
and furious movies knowing what to do
doesn't come from up here it comes from
here but it can't
CBGB's has been closed since 2006 sure
Gargamel is a wizard but he has no
wand'ring potions or spells at this
point so how the hell was he able to
control these flies baby but where did
they get a crib off can you really book
every ad space in Times Square and then
not send the final ad until overnight
the night before it's supposed to air I
don't think that's how advertising works
nobody sees this wow I'm just gonna stop
counting ripoffs but this movie threw us
more toy story that mean it's so obvious
it demands to be called out Breaking and
Entering geez that's how many laws of
these Smurf suckers broken so far
[Music]
Gargamel here's this asshole singing the
Smurf song and that guy just saw the
Smurfs going into a bookstore
apparently I'm calling it ape this movie
ex machina also the spook stores in
Chinatown and Gargamel was just in
Central Park me as this movie ever
actually been to New York once again day
turns to night on a mother smurfing dime
either these Smurfs or these pigeons
knew how to get from the bookstore back
to Patrick's house either way I'm not
buying it this movie wanted a walking
tough as a group scene and it's somehow
decided to go with back and black as the
underneath song maybe blue by LeAnn
Rimes is too slow maybe I'm blue by
Eiffel 65 is too fast but if you're
telling me there are zero rock songs
with the word blue in the title that go
well under a badass here or walk scene
and you are lying they have a War Chant
I thought this was a village that only
experienced happiness I guess that also
covers bloodlust they did all that with
him flying by drone and dragging this
bowling ball balloon contraption just to
drop it on Gargamel that's it
one bowling ball shot and what are the
odds who even actually hit it this seems
like a super overly complicated attack
with very little chance of success as I
watch this Smurfs tornado I'm left to
wonder how was the plan not to lure
Gargamel out here then have Patrick hit
him in the head and beat his old ass
with that crowbar instead of this Smurfs
only attack and Patrick opened that
thing for Smurfs that ages ago so where
the hell is he you could end this fight
easy he's just waiting there do
something dude this is like not playing
LeBron in the NBA Finals yes the
Scottish Smurfs just yelled freedom this
movie thinks that's funny well which
movie are they ripping off here
final destination let's go with that
just because I don't want to take the
time to list down all the other movies
where this happens also that bus driver
who never honked in the first place
isn't even thinking about stopping after
he just plowed into a man I believe more
in a vision
well the visions had literally never
been wrong before so you were right to
think that way I'm honestly shocked this
one particular vision was wrong
what Papa's vision abilities are now in
doubt if I was a smurf my whole world
would be shattered hey deal I just
called to say thank you
oh good Patrick gets to keep his job
which was definitely the most important
part of this movie finally someone has
given me what I want yeah but he had to
literally color the moon to do it is he
gonna be held to that standard from now
on oh no that is just not appropriate
look we are capacity okay we'll let some
people we don't want to clears out a
little you get right here if you go back
to end of the line
[Music]
[Applause]
Skywalker
you will die look at the size of that
boy's heat I'm not kidding it's like an
orange on a toothpaste
[Music]
spark tags what is your profession these
stupid Smurfs go on a huge adventure to
New York City and end up living with
Doogie Howser for a while and what would
have been ideal is if Doogie had been a
nature back of customer once again
things that could have been brought to
my attention yesterday then he'd already
have tasty healthy snacks in his home
when stupid Smurfs show up and he could
provide them with nourishment and energy
after their long journey he could have
gone to naturebox calm and even gotten
50% off his first order then he could
have been all why Oh strange little blue
friends you look hungry how about some
lentil loops or blueberry nom noms and
everyone would have been delighted
instead he plays guitar hero with them
and they go to a bookstore and Hank
Azaria shows up with that ridiculous CGI
CAD and well you see what happens when
you don't have naturebox snacks on hand
pandemonium so before you find yourself
unexpectedly playing host to super
annoying tiny cartoon creatures with
nothing on hand to feed them get your
butt to naturebox calm down or
constantly add new snacks and flavors
for place anything you don't like for
free and our fans get 50% off their
first order
I mean Smurf me that's a great deal so
get going you and you and you over there
and everybody go that would mean no